this video
changed
at all i'm pretty sure i watched more
youtube videos than anyone else here in
the studio i don't think i've seen
this williams is the best yeah he wrote
star wars too all right
it's the end of 2018
and i want to hear from you guys
the best videos
why are you so angry i don't have the
best videos i don't watch youtube i make
videos i've been spending all your
making videos i don't have time to watch
videos you've definitely watched some
good youtube videos avatar last time for
a second time i've watched atlanta
season 2. i need all you guys to pick
out one video that is the best video on
youtube of 2018. that is hard work to do
i have so much work to do this is work i
have no no no no no
i only want to see it if it's the
coolest video of the whole year look at
my schedule uh i thought this would be
like a sick like compilation video like
all the best videos
like dictating pull some things out of
my head
the first video i want to throw out
there from my best video 2018 is so
crispy media's do not touch 360 vr video
the reason this is my one of my best
videos of 2018 is one it's really hard
to make good 360 videos and they did it
two they use a really
special ai visual like visualization
technique that i've been waiting to see
people use and they actually use it the
an ai machine learning algorithm kind of
figure out where patterns are in the
painting and you can apply those
painting blotches of style
to a picture or in this case to a video
so these guys managed to create an idea
around that it looks amazing nobody else
has done anything like it and it's in
360 vr i feel like 2018 was kind of the
year of like everybody found their
formulas and stuck to it it's like
nothing quite stands out but here's a
guy who is
totally kicking the formula and like
doing his own
[Music]
it's been a thing
hasn't it
everyone else might have forgotten what
you did but i don't forget so easily
i catch your ass and give you 40 of my
phone battery if that wasn't enough for
you to protect our ongoing friendship
hell i would have just given you the
money
who is this needs to go down to the
playlist to find out oh plug
oh
i got a video this video
changed
at all the interview that joe rogan did
with matthew walker
it's a good one i watched it twice yeah
same this is the first joe rogan podcast
i ever listened to and he just drops the
knowledge dude matthew walker he's like
a sleep scientist for two hours straight
he drops sleep bombs on you guys there's
so much tied to not getting sleep like
cancer is tied to not getting sleep
alzheimer's is tied to not getting sleep
practice does not make perfect practice
with a night of sleep is what makes
perfect because you come back the next
day and you're 20 to 30 percent better
in terms of your skilled performance
than where you were at the end of your
practice session the day before
wow
wow wow to movies with mikey if you're
not watching movies mikey you absolutely
have to he's hilarious two-parter on how
we see star
wars a new hope was just the first form
we ever saw of star wars gary arnold
writing for the washington post said
george lucas has made the kind of sci-fi
adventure movie you dream about finding
quite famously pauline kale of the new
yorker wrote and it is all as exciting
as last year's weather reports
one of my favorite youtube channels is
the slow-mo guys they basically blew up
a bunch of det cord in this uh place at
the colorado school of mines oh
which
oh
the explosion was so big they broke
their phantom camera oh
do everything away look at the camera
oh my god oh my god
it honestly looks like that was fired
from a fat man it does
but what it's the short and the
technology they used to make it was like
my favorite part what's the technology
you used to make this this is all this
is all blender
oh yeah remember you showing me this all
of it the 3d the 2d
compositing everything wow that's
impressive yeah blender's got some
really cool like cartoon animation tools
now like you see like rim lighting
like none of that is drawn in it's just
uh you have your base colors
and then you just added an effect it's
just rim light so and for part two is
like they're taking a lot of
the shots they're doing they show how
they do it as
well i think i'm going to give it to
one of my favorite musical artists of
the year saw him live two nights ago
travis gambino this is america music
video
came out that's a good hit this is
america that's that was on my list i saw
him live on sunday scrolling by even
playing this
[Music]
okay why
why is this shared with me why am i
watching this
[Music]
this guy's been making these
it's just very satisfying to watch
because he he's got the his rendering
stuff really really down
[Music]
actually stay tuned because we're about
to do some secret santas
i guess i really don't know what
christmas is all about
[Music]
what's up jake
uh we got a problem dude yeah yeah we
got a serious problem around here
there's no christmas spirit in the
studio we've gone all year prepared for
the end of the year with our videos and
our business but we haven't done
anything to promote the christmas spirit
dang bro we need to do something about
this because the last thing that i want
is for everyone to go off on christmas
break to enjoy a holiday and not feel
like they got the love we should do a
secret santa everyone you pick a name
out of a hat everyone gets a name
they've got to buy a gift for that
person okay minor problem we close
tomorrow so we've got less than 24 hours
to do this and uh we haven't even told
everybody yet how do you expect us to
get these christmas presents in time how
do you expect santa to get to every
house on christmas eve he uses the
christmas spirit
so over the years we've seen the street
change quite a bit from a little quiet
run down alleyway where we started
shooting our videos to now a hustling
and bustling street in downtown los
angeles some of you have been with us
from the beginning of this journey and
some of you have just joined us but one
thing is remain consistent throughout
all this and that is the support of our
patrons you guys have made it possible
for us to stay above the winds of
youtube and you let us grow our team and
bring new people on board and explore
ideas that may not always be
commercially viable but still ideas that
we're passionate about and want to make
and you guys have enabled it so i want
to say thank you to all of you that have
supported us on patreon you guys have
really made a big difference in the
studio and the team that you see here on
corridor crew it would not be that team
without you guys and we want to shout
out a couple of special people who have
been with us for quite a while here
phillip oxford nathan mcfarlane
nathan mcfarlane
yo
pull over get into the nathan mcfarlane
[Music]
g squared
taylor dunbar colin heaton
mitch polinski
james bailey and brian and hozick
smells like santa's in here
you smell that
smells like gingerbread
sprinkles
oh there's a
there's a cone in there there's no cone
in there that's not my head that's my
head shape
do stuff dude dude i ain't got time for
stuff inside you're gonna stand there
and tell me that hat is not stuffed
right now oh see this hat this stands on
its own it looks a little saggy to me oh
you should should have had the name of
the receiver on the gift
i've prepared
as well wait dude
santa is on a secret mission this year
and he's got gifts for everyone it's
just the promise we don't know who santa
truly is
oh it's not actually santa it's one of
us point the whole point is to be like
who got me this freaking thing and
you're like it was me like that's the
point of this today
[Music]
all right
i know a gift that goes to somebody and
i'm going to give it to that person it's
not for me
and that person has to guess
who gave it to them all right and we're
going to do that
nick
somebody told me to give this to you
thank you it's not for me
christmas present
[Music]
what is it
[Music]
holy crap
don't be jealous dude this is my
presence is that a real shrimp are those
lobsters it's just
oh these are shrimps
i like this how big are
those are good
you the tartar sauce i can't i can't
vouch for it for those of you who don't
know he's been running this
subreddit our slash shrimp memes in here
nick and nick has single-handedly been
keeping that sub alive
all right friends thank you cliff
i've been informed
that there's a gift here for you i love
gifts yay it is not for me from the
question mark is this a bag it is a bag
and this is oh battery 4 400 million
power at 3.7 volts you can charge your
phone all over and over
you just add this one
[Music]
what is it shake it is it a lego please
don't be meat please don't be meat
it's more fun
it's a medium
indigo
originals from
[Music]
indigo prince los angeles 2017 oh that's
cool dude that's really nice
an elf has informed me
meat is for you
oh really whoa
i'm really not liking how good these
gifts are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
oh my goodness
ice cream from salt and straw this is
such a good gift good gift
a fresh ice cream
that has been sitting in there for like
three hours now is this a new run
yeah
i was like there's one thing you got to
know about nico he loves his ice cream i
love salt and strawberries
very unexpected raw shrimp and ice cream
man
this is what i was afraid of yes they
even went to the extent of prince i know
you like these things you can control
pea
[Music]
who got who pulled this out of the
fridge upstairs
all right and my name tag back
sticks
that is awesome i have been looking all
over for these two things
because jared right that's correct
[Music]
merry christmas
i've never seen anyone more distressed
than jared when we came when it came
time to doing this because it's very
apparent you have to put so much care
and effort into gifts and we didn't give
you that option no you did not i really
hated everything about this
is this butcher paper someone just got
me some deals
[Applause]
we brought our own food
what is going on
probably niko
it's just like who's most likely to go
to worry market to jarrett from santa oh
jolly old saint nick father christmas i
like the bag very very 50 chance that
it's the mouse
yeah yeah it could be there
there's a
chrome book light is that what's in here
yes there's a chrome book booklight
and
i don't know what hold on there's a note
maybe oh these might be coins
yeah i wonder who could give me old
coins
oh there's only oh whoa
these are nice though dude
like you can see the face and everything
on there
you don't even have to guess like it
just walks over
and elf has told me that santa made this
just
for you
[Music]
suey
what is it
a bunch of microphones
[Music]
so we got one more present here and it's
on the tree for our very own elf
do that faking he's just first taker
there you go
what's that pom-pom
is it food again is it a sea urchin
it might be
freaking
garbage
crinkle paper free treats
and
[Laughter]
a cat toy
and a cat toy
it's a cat toy
the cat toys
[Laughter]
no it's a free treat
i have a treat
free treat
i know exactly what it is what is this
is just took it off the tree and put it
it's
garbage
in the sock i wonder who that was clint
is it carmichael
it's like it's a cat toys
we're both cat parents so i figured we
got some free treats when we ordered
some medicine
we have a couple of these for our cats
and we play catch with them they love it
okay that was dramatic as like
i thought jarrett was gonna have the
worst gift
but you know clint pulled it out and
said asked if this was garbage
you can't get any worse than that
imagine
you open a box and that's the first
thing you say
it's a garbage
okay that's so amazing
merry christmas everyone
merry christmas
it's only like kinda off
it's like it's almost
that was hilarious i'm so glad we did
this hope you enjoyed 2018. 2019 is
going to be even better
subscribe if you're not
we'll see you next year
about to go to the end of the year
corridor dinner here at tokyo wakoza
hibachi place earlier today clint gifted
me these shrimp so
i'm gonna see if i can ask the chef to
throw them on the grill for me
so they don't go to waste what's the
percent that you think they're gonna
take these shrimps and cook them or they
say what percent is the render at
chances that they'll take our
bring your own shrimps
i don't know man well i brought some
right here
yeah
he's not the chef so he said just tell
the chefs
[Music]
[Music]
many times many ways merry christmas
to you